これから外れ社長です loading 皆さんしたことはありますでしょうか
ボーリングの玉ってめちゃくちゃ多いんですよ
b スポーツ登れにやった人ならわかると思うんですけども b スポーツでこうやっ
てボウリングの球を投げる前のこの動作のここで手を離して
ローディングが後ろにそんな時までの観客だわー
になるかもあるんですよそれを実際にやってみようと思いますでこの投げるときに思
ボーリング球を投げたらさせ危なくて気がするんで春井ボーリング頭を準備しようとし
たんですけども登壇店舗数のお笑い芸人の方々がこういう時に行ってましてそのカレー
falling 玉どこで手に入れたんだろうと思っていろいろ調べたんですけども
売ってないんです
どこにはなくてえこれどうすればいいんだろうと思ったとを作りマスター
作りましたそういう特殊なものを作るところにお願いして作りました自分で40万円し
ました
こちらですこんな値段を払って真似したいのかと言われるとちょっと分からないんです
けどもうしたいんですよ
oo こちらですもうどう見てもボーリングないんだよこちらめちゃくちゃ軽い
ボーリング玉ネスちゃんとさんと穴までついてますどうでしょ
バサッとにどっからどう見ても某激ヤバなんですけどもめっちゃ軽いんですよ
トータルで坊さんのドッキリはめちゃくちゃ面白くて
そう好きで僕もやってみようと思ったんですけど
ボーリングの玉のこのカレーに様々な来て論じ分払って作るしかねえというわけで作っ
てみましたさすがにボーリングエコで投げる直前こと投げられてこれが飛んできて怖く
ない人は絶対いないと思って
なりとなんか世の中にある時の中で一番声がボウリングが違ったつに飛んでくる ok
だと思うんですよ
絶対強いよだってボーリング食べて何キロぐらいかな
もうず10キロ20分があるんだけどももう嫌
怖いよほぼ鉄球滝だり吸ってくるみたいなもんですからね
ただして突然ボーディングの球が打ち方から投げられたら人はどういう反応するん
でしょうか
さっそくやっていきましょうかはい
なぁ今日はおりちゃーん号リングせよ小宇宙
なんだイエスはどれぐらいですかフォークよくて九十数100230だねぇ
凍っ
まあ6分
rar
ええええええ
ああああああ
car
me
[音楽]
wh
goo
me
ありがとうございます
あっございますすごいやん
いわし
恋ばーわー
[音楽]
me
dea
car
me あった
ああああああ
あっ発揮夏山
これが楽しんでいてこれもよろしくお願いたいなあー